I've come up with five, easy to implement steps...
...that can take your calendar from working against you to working for you.
And they really work.
We worked with a big global company...
...and asked some of their leaders to put these tips into practice while others didn't.
And guess what?
The leaders who used these steps...
...saw significant hours open up on their calendars for, you know, actual work.
Tip number one: Ask yourself, "Do you really need the meeting?"
We're under the illusion that we need a meeting for everything.
We think "I need to make sure so-and-so is okay with this, so I'll book time."...
...or "I've got a quick question on process, I'll grab a meeting."
The reality is, for almost half of the meetings we schedule,...
...we could simply pick up the phone or shoot a text for a quick answer.
A trick to stop this:...
...when you're thinking of calling a meeting, write the invitation first.
And if you can't start with a subject line with an action verb,...
...you shouldn't have the meeting.
"Decide, finalize, create next steps."
Those are reasons to call a meeting.
"Review," on the other hand, isn't an action verb.